welcome back to me rockstars i'm eric
voss and the batman trailer shows robert
pattinson investigating who
used the last of the duct tape was it
paul dano as a riddler or
is the who in that question really
referring to the court of
owls the shadowy dc villains i explained
in yesterday's video
who could be the masterminds pulling the
strings to even batman himself
go check out that video if you haven't
already i broke down the court's source
material history and laid out my case
for how they could tie into the batman
movie plot
here i'm gonna go back through this
trailer frame by frame to point out the
many owl sightings and references hiding
in plain sight to show you
how legit my theory could actually be
spoiler warning for all things the
batman
all things owls and how many owl licks
it takes to get to the center of a
disappointing lollipop oh the raspberry
part's over
if there's anything i can't stand it's a
smart album okay the first and most
obvious owl sighting in the trailer is
the riddler's first clue
the love note left for the batman at the
crime scene the riddle wasn't just the
word play inside the card which we have
decoded what does a liar do when he's
dead he
lies still the riddle was also the card
itself
a weird-ass gropy skeleton trying to
make friends with an owl who hoots
which i pointed out earlier this week
was a turn of phrase achieved by adding
an extra
o which the riddler also does with the
second clue making the
d.a district attorney doa dead on
arrival
also worth noting on the cover of this
card is a bat
in the moon essentially the bat signal
but with a bat
way smaller in that circle and more
insignificant
and in the court of owl comics it is
pointed out how owls
are natural predators of bats they're
also predators of my heart
i love birds so before we even open the
riddler's car to try to decipher his
message he is already screaming at us
hello batman these owls are coming for
you and they got spooky skeletons in
their closet so look out okay
next in recent videos i've combined this
clue with the riddler's later cryptic
words
if you are justice please
do not lie what is the price
for your blind
a rhyming phrase that could contain
multiple meanings but one that i
ultimately interpreted as a nod
to lady justice who is blindfolded an
icon of the
court room so owl plus court equals
owl of quartz court of owls now in
recent days many have posted what they
believe to be another court of owl's
sighting in the trailer
the shot when batman ascends the
stairwell he passes by someone who
for one brief frame appears to be
wearing
a white owl mask okay look
while i love the obsessive frame by
frame clue hunting i might have helped
inspire across the internet
we call it frame by frame because you
can't just look at one frame out of
context
this person's face is just illuminated
white because a gunshot flash
overexposed their face
with their perfectly angled jawline a
few frames before and a few frames after
it's just a normal face i'm sorry to
force you to roll up that jump to
conclusions matt the real issue with
this being a court of owl's mask is the
court
never wears their white masks out in
public like this
their power comes from the people of
gotham thinking they're a mythical urban
legend
they're the devils who tricked the world
into thinking they didn't exist
and if dumbass juror number 12 were to
walk around in public he'd probably get
a talent sent for his head
however you're not wrong for keeping
your eye peeled for this kind of image
because at a different part of the
trailer batman confronts linda kyle when
she breaks into the crime scene what is
selena doing here by the way i'll
explore that in tomorrow's episode of
rogue theory but for now look at the
shelf behind batman
every other time in this trailer that
we've been in this room the camera has
been pointed elsewhere but in this one
brief angle
on the shelf is a white mask it's out of
focus but it's not too much of a stretch
to suggest
this mask could be one of the court of
owls hiding in plain sight among the
mayor's many collectibles
it also wouldn't be too surprising to
see owl imagery in this room
because i don't think it's the only owl
clue hiding in the crime scene but
before we intend you thank you to
skillshare for sponsoring this video
skillshare is an online learning
community that offers membership with
meaning with
so much to explore real projects to
create and the support of fellow
creatives skillshare empowers you to
accomplish real
growth skillshare offers classes
designed for real life you can learn and
grow with short classes that fit
any schedule spontaneous acts of
creativity may help
break up the routine of a day spent
indoors and learning is a great way to
fend off boredom
they have classes and topics new
rockstars fans will enjoy like animation
film video
music production class i'm really
interested in checking out is science
fiction and fantasy
creating unique and powerful worlds
taught by lincoln michelle a creative
writing professor at columbia and sarah
lawrence the class focuses on how to
create new and unique worlds
while having those worlds reflect back
on us and make us see
our reality differently skillshare is
curated specifically for learning there
are no ads and they are always launching
new premium classes so you can stay
focused
and follow wherever your creativity
takes you and it's less than 10
a month with an annual subscription and
the first 1 000 of my subscribers to
click the link in the description will
get a two-month free trial of premium
membership
so you can explore your creativity just
click the link in the description below
okay back to the owl clues of this crime
scene one of the other details we
spotted in our breakdown but didn't
linger on for too long was the body's
left hand when the cops have arrived a
paper bag is covering it
but earlier when the riddler was alone
with this dead mare you can see
something on the left hand maybe a ring
i believe this ring may have been
removed maybe debased
maybe something added to the finger
maybe the whole finger or the hand was
severed
it reminds me a lot of the court of
owl's comic which opens with a corpse
that upon an autopsy investigation
reveals a tooth filling
imprinted with an image of an owl the
first of many clues leading to batman's
discovery
of the court of owl's existence this
messed with hand
may be a similar first clue in this
movie also it might be nothing but the
mayor's office also contained a portrait
of a creepy old dude
which i get lots of people keep creepy
portraits around their homes to scream
at while they swirl their scotch
but it's also possible that the identity
of this old dude could be someone who
ties
into the court of owl's long history
running gotham city from the shadows an
operation that could have helped don
mitchell jr
win his third term but an operation now
finally getting brought to light with
his murder some have also said there's
another possible owl citing on the suv
of who we believe to be peter starsgaard
as district attorney gil coulson
crashing mitchell's funeral with the
riddler's next clue and a neckbomb the
lettering on the window behind coulson
does
look to be kind of like illustrated
something else has been drawn in there
maybe
but the frames where the car passes
bruce during his dive the letters do
look like d
o and a so i'm thinking maybe the window
glass has just been shattered but the
real detail here
is the portrait of the mayor in the
later shot when the bomb explodes you
can see that portrait shows him wearing
a red lapel pin in the comics a huge
realization
comes when bruce thinking his battle
with the court of owls is over sees a
portrait of his mother and father
with martha wearing a misshapen heart
lapel pen
exactly like the one once described to
bruce
by the mayoral candidate lincoln march
who said his mother
gave him a pin like that and leads to
some real crazy twists involving the
wayne family again
go check out yesterday's video for that
breakdown i think this pin
could be a similar kind of clue pointing
to the late mayor's involvement with the
court of owls
a discovery that bruce could make when
he later re-examines the charred
remnants of this
blast crater but perhaps the biggest
clue is one that we've had under our
noses for months
everyone's favorite moment of the
trailer when batman beats the piss out
of this stuff
very briefly during the hits you can see
batman's gauntlets which are lined with
these quill-like projectiles
almost exactly like the gauntlets worn
by talon in the comics
talon is the executioner of the court of
owls the one they deploy to assassinate
rising threats to their control of
gotham yesterday's video ended with my
theory that this young batman could be
secretly being used as an
unwitting executioner by the court of
owls taking cases from a corrupt
criminal justice system that they put in
place
now the riddler is breaking down that
system to expose batman to his
own role in the system that he has been
casting a blind eye to
you're part of this too oh my part of it
you'll see yeah you'll see are the final
words
your blind eye earlier riddler is
promising to cure
batman of his blindness so maybe we're
not so crazy for seeing a white owl mask
flashing past batman in the heat of the
moment even if it was an illusion
because this is going to be a story
about batman's perception widening to
see threats hiding in plain sight all
around him
evolving him into the cynical paranoid
dark knight that we know him to be
this guy might just start seeing owls
everywhere just like
us again stay tuned for tomorrow's rogue
theory episode for more on
how selena kyle fits into all of this i
really do think she's the final piece of
the puzzle
help us decode the mystery on new
rockstar's official discord server which
you can access by becoming a patron
at any tier at patreon.comrockstars
follow me on instagram at eavos follow
me rockstars subscribe and hit that
notification bell for the latest deep
dives into everything you care about
thanks for watching batman
[Music]
you
[Music]